The David Pakman show subreddit now has nearly
14,000 subscribers.
Um, this is a great place for people to talk
amongst themselves about politics to suggest
ideas for the show. Uh, we have one of the
largest independent progressive media subreddits
and it is increasingly active with a lot of
good stuff and stuff I don't agree with, which
is totally fine. One Post I noticed this morning
is a post from someone named everybody loves
crayon saying, David needs to stop with the
Shtick that candidates like Warren and Bernie
aren't far left in the context of modern American
politics. They are, maybe they aren't far
left when compared to David's personal views,
but they are in modern American politics.
David loses credibility with people like me
on the right. When he says stuff like this,
you can't just compare them to other countries
in Nordic countries. They're not far left.
So what? We're not in Nordic country or any
other non American country.
This is a very typical right-wing view, which
is as he says, it's not, we're not any non-American
country. We are America. Therefore everything
has to be evaluated solely in the context
of what is normal in America. That's a loser's
game and the person says, you know, I, I lose
there on the right. I lose credibility with
them. When I say Bernie and Warren are not
far right, I would lose credit quote credibility
with you for something else. You're, you're
not the person that I need to maintain credibility
with. You have a very narrow American centric
view merely because you live in the United
States understand that the world is more than
the United States. I'm trying to present a
perspective on this channel now on my, on
my show that tells us, just because you're
a US-based blinders give you one impression
doesn't mean that when you expand your horizons,
you realize the very different political reality
of the world.
So that's why I you, the whole point here
is to say, yeah, we have a very skewed view
in the United States of what is considered
far left. When you look at any other developed
rich country like ours, anywhere in the world,
they have a healthcare system that makes sense.
They deal with gun control in a way that makes
more sense, et cetera. So I, I completely
reject what it is that you're saying here.
And if I've lost credibility with you, because
I'm telling you the reality that in the United
States you have an Overton window that is
far to the right of where it should be given
what other countries are doing and have achieved.
Uh, then, I'm sorry, I guess I'm not credible
on that basis. Another post from the subreddit,
a very interesting article on Huffington post,
which encourages Beto O'Rourke to pick a race
that he can win.
This is a exactly what I have been saying
for a couple of months now. Beto O'Rourke
in the first democratic debate imploded. He
lost any chance he had to be the Democratic
nominee. Doesn't mean he's a bad guy and it
certainly doesn't mean that I wouldn't love
to see Beto replace a senator in Texas. He
failed to do so with Ted Cruz in 2018, but
maybe he could do it with John Cornyn in 2020
and I set it what it must, six, eight weeks
ago, Beto should abandon the presidential
campaign, go back to Texas and use his national
recognition to run against John Cornyn. Uh,
there are now more and more op-eds that are
suggesting he do exactly that. I love it.
He should do it. He's got no shot to win the
Democratic nomination. Some people I know
will write in and say, David, he has no shot
to defeat John Cornyn.
He can get in the way of John Cornyn in a
very significant way, causing Republicans
in Texas and nationally to have to spend a
ton of money to defend that seat. It will
weaken Texas for Republicans if Beto simply
does as well as he did against Ted Cruz, and
I actually think he could win. Um, it would
be a fight, but I think that he could win.
So really glad that people on the subreddit
are pointing to that. Join the David Pakman
show subreddit@davidpakman.com slash reddit
that's r e d d it, I think before we know
it, we're going to have a 15,000 sub reddit
subscribers. They're very exciting stuff.